so today's topic I saw a news article
about somebody who's trans ratio so we
brought in Paul because the person
claimed that they were transportation
but it is the motor transportation in
Thailand
yeah with Japanese [ __ ] yeah yeah I like
to be black so I wear my somebody or
where I go whenever I'm around the muse
that come around the food
he says he's around the music probably
talk about Bruno Mars you like I'm in my
own skin
I'd watch The History Channel sometimes
for hours and you know nothing else
intrigues me more but you know things
about you know Filipino culture whoever
wanted the History Channel and some
hours and hours on Philippines yeah that
doesn't happen so he's like a hundred
and fifty years old I'm very suspicious
already I think if you're unhappy with
who you are and you change yourself for
the better and that makes you happy you
know go for it but it's I I would never
say it was a privilege to you know be
unhappy with yourself all the time well
the funny thing is is you know I had to
make sure that it wasn't just me because
if it's just me then there must be
something wrong or maybe I'm just
people started to message me about you
know their confliction with themselves
my family knows about my transsexuality
but they don't know anything about this
it's just my mom is kind of an older
world person your mom's on all the world
person you're an other world person
your mom's obviously older than you
that's the way time works yeah if your
mom was younger than you [ __ ]
psychologist side to chime in I really
think that before you get offended you
need to think about what they're doing
are they hurting you are they hurting
anyone else are they hurting themselves
and are they just trying to be who they
feel they are inside and being the best
person possible so more people can
really accept who they are the better
our world is gonna be if I was born
Canada or in Canada both my parents from
the Philippines hmm so that's just
geographical facts about my life yeah
it'd make me Filipino yeah regardless of
how I feel and how do you how much how
much do you think we should participate
someone else's own self-identification
can we don't or don't we become part of
the problem yeah because if we
acknowledge this I get like oh we should
accept people as we are and so if you
want to say your Filipino say a Filipino
just the same way I have the right to
say I don't acknowledge that fact or the
Filipino community has a right to reject
that fact
you guys both all have those rights but
my question becomes at which point
there's someone's self-identification
become foul in the wheel because I think
there's a grant that comes out for
Filipinos who gets to decide who gets to
have access that grant what are the
standards by which we decide whether
someone's part of a culture say it's not
so clear-cut you don't say it's one of
my best friends he's white white white
like boiled potatoes white but he's
Jamaican the first time I've seen like a
black shiny I was [ __ ] I was like what
and the shiniest Chinese man I am if I
it would all right my Manya
you want some curries and checking in
this goodness [ __ ] would [ __ ]
that life but this dude is this scam
just a scam that's damn everyone I
talked to who studies anthropology said
the answers very there's no clear-cut
thing so as much Taiwan announces
presidents say they're [ __ ] running
this and that day I'm like what are the
standards by which the RET you did what
I'm saying if you have to decide what
grants are and what who gets the grants
and who does this and knew this that and
this and that you have to unfortunately
cross a line right you have to make a
line you have to decide okay there
person is and there's not field in the
in the field there's not none of that if
you ever if you you cause everybody
feeling he should give the [ __ ] grant
you know I mean ya know if there's good
fit
I'll pay for the peanut candy she don't
say you know I'm still waiting cuz it
gets dangerous right cuz you're saying
there's that line but through all this
the line just keeps getting pushed a
little bit further it's a regional yeah
so people are trying to figure it out
maybe it's it's like I don't like the
white person like privilege yeah that
don't say anything in the world I don't
say so why can't I just be you don't you
don't even have any drivel if you think
white privilege
nobody really gets [ __ ] from being for
the middle you can't even see what
privilege that damn no I try to lay in
the cut people's trying to do it's a
tough one yeah and like you said you
know the white person can feel like they
can transition from white to Filipino
but Philippine will never have that
luxury no matter where they go they're
always gonna be regarded as a Filipino
immigrants or how they feel on the
inside you don't have to associate
yourself with any of the hardships that
come with that or in the negative
downsides
you get to have all the benefits of
being paul de filipino without any of
the downsides that's kinda like driving
a Ford Focus and then thinking you can
go through life without ever being made
fun of that's not the way it works you
drive the car you gotta take what comes
with it cuz I'd love to be able to wake
up tomorrow and be a middle-aged white
woman and never have cops bother me but
that's just not gonna happen in the real
world so I think we have to have a
serious discussion about this but I'm
curious for you audience members how do
you feel like how much do you feel like
we should participate in someone's own
self identify
and how do you guys determine whether
someone's part of a culture or not
because we don't necessarily have the
answers but these are all right
questions to be asked opinion cuz I was
ready to roast this too but I was ready
and I'm like okay this is why he's wrong
and as I started to rhyme with uh you're
not part of this culture because I'm
like wait is that real reason you're not
part and then I couldn't figure it out
and I'm like wait what does it mean to
be an african-american what does it mean
to be a black person to be nice to open
how do we determine all these lines and
then you realize everything hey hey Oh
[Laughter]
Victor Paul for coming off of this yeah
yeah tell us what you guys think got
anything else you wanna ask no I'm good
Filipinos say it what Rivlin don't take
away Lisi so that's it for today's video
be sure to share it like subscribe
comment leave comments to read it but we
never reply if you guys wanna follow us
we got a YouTube Instagram page all that
stuff you know
share it boom dank below that see y'all
soon next week you know a dollar makes
me holler